hey everybody and then welcome to
another hd tutorial um this one is by
request by a user who uh goes by
cundiff13
and what i want to talk about today is
how to stop applications from um from
running in the background now if you
have a computer that actually doesn't
have a whole lot of ram you're trying to
max out your battery
obviously having more ram helps you
not access the hard drive quite as much
but if you do have a lot of things
running in the background you can see
this by going to processes and starting
by memory and like firefox is using a
ton of memory even though it's not open
so you may have a number of things such
as preloaders or minimize to trays or
instant messengers that actually use a
lot of ram and that could suck up your
battery life so i'm going to show you
today how to
remove those from your um from your
computer so first of all down in the
bottom right hand corner in either
windows xp or windows vista you'll have
this called the system tray
if something you saw that in that was in
the task manager seems to be taking a
lot of ram you simply right click it and
find the option that somehow unloads the
firefox or firefox preloader or whatever
is using too much ram so right now it's
using a lot of ram as a firefox
preloader so i'm going to unload firefox
preloader hit yes
and that'll save a bunch of ram you can
keep looking in the system tray for
other things that you're not using that
are running in the background such as
the chameleon web browser preloader i
can exit that
um
i'm not using thunderbird because i'm
not connected to this wireless network
that i'm near so i'm going to right
click it and hit close thunderbird
all these things save me quite a bit of
ram and as you can see if i open up task
manager again
uh the highest uh the highest memory
priority is now just the windows desktop
manager which is only using 46 megabytes
of ram so just a very simple tip hope
that helped you guys um that's just a
quick way to free up a little bit more
battery life if i'm not using aerosnap
just hit close a lot of them have this
quick little built-in menu where you can
either customize or unload things that
are occupying your ramp so i hope this
tutorial was helpful thanks and if uh if
you have any more requests such as i
will put out kind of 13's link in the
description so you can click on his page
subscribe to him he does a lot of nice
videos
so um if anyone has any other nice uh
video tutorial tips or
uh so you have requests that you'd like
me to do just send me a just subscribe
to my channel and send me a personal
message and i will do my best thanks for
watching peace